this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
what's up guys michael here to talk
about the patron saint of blowing stuff
up
michael bay occupies a weird space
within cinema his movies typically rake
in the bucks at the box office yet
critical discussion of his work tends to
question bay's directorial merit you
could argue that his films are somewhat
meaningless and vapid and plenty of
people do but a sizable audience keeps
coming back for that beautified
explosion happy glory so what's going on
here how did we end up in a world with
five transformers movies is michael bay
just a glorified popcorn salesman or are
there deeper things at play in his work
strap in people we're going deeper dumb
on michael bay but before we dive in i
want to talk about this video sponsor
surfsharkvpn searchvpn keeps your data
safe as you navigate the internet thanks
to secure protocols and uncrackable
encryption among the many advantages of
using a secure vpn like surfshark is
that the internet can't figure out where
in the world i'm located so that means i
can shop for plane tickets without
getting price gouged all by connecting
to vpns in different countries until i
track down the best deal it's also super
handy for watching movies and tv shows
that have been released in other
countries all you need is one
subscription to cover all of your
favorite devices like your laptop
playstation xbox amazon firestick and
beyond and on your go to apps like
firefox and chrome which also have
options for a vpn click the link in the
description and use the promo code
wisecrack to get 83 off plus three extra
months for free go to surfshark.deals
wisecrack or hit the link in the
description protect yourself online and
download surfsharkvpn today and now back
to the show now opinions on michael bay
are a dime a dozen on one side you've
got the haters often critics like mark
kermode who reviewed transformers 4 in
the form of a youtube video in which he
bangs his head against a wall don't
forget that time roger ebert suggested
you skip what was then the most recent
michael bay film and instead
go into the kitchen cue up a male choir
singing the music of hell and get a kid
to start banging pots and pans together
then close your eyes and use your
imagination
i miss the days we used to have real
critics indeed critics have made a tidy
little side hustle out of duncan on bay
but is the vitriol overdone after all
there is enjoyment to be found in his
work he's a technical master who can cox
undeniably hearty visual feasts in fact
this is what informs the probate crowd
who argue that because bae has an
identifiable and consistent style he
should be considered an auteur auteur
theory essentially developed because
french film theorists wanted to elevate
film to the heights of say literature by
positing the director of a film as being
the equivalent to the author of a book
and warning if you bring up auteur
theory at a party you do risk being
considered insufferable
auteur theorists believe that the best
works of cinema should necessarily show
the personal stamp of the director via a
signature style as well as recurrent
visual and narrative preoccupations
popular art tours include hitchcock
campion and del toro but as we'll
explore bay doesn't quite fit in this
club now bay might take issue with the
very premise of this video of hollywood
he said what we do is not brain surgery
we are entertainers plain and simple and
we're responsible to bring that money
back to make a profit he's also noted
that these are just [ __ ] movies
they're supposed to be fun rather than
defending the intellectual or artistic
merit of his films the way some of his
fans might bae seems to express a
willful detachment from any notions of
ideology or meaning in his work
according to him a michael bay film is
just entertainment just a product and we
should treat it as such but it doesn't
quite work like that it's basically
impossible to tell a cinematic story
without ideology creeping in whether or
not that ideology is intentional film
critics jean-luc camoli and jean narboni
once claimed that every film is
political for this exact reason
blockbuster films like bays have huge
amounts of money and resources poured
into their production and the people
pouring that money in typically have
certain ideological expectations more
esoterically camolia and narpony argued
that the very nature of cinema itself
meant that ideology is inescapable to
them the medium of film is an artistic
rendering of reality complete with all
the biases and beliefs of the creators
so depending on things like where a
movie was made and the background of the
director certain ideologies are sure to
be represented in the movie in some way
this means that not only can we
potentially glean a director's personal
ideology via their work but arguably
more importantly we can look at the
output of broader groups of creators to
define dominant ideologies so it's worth
asking is there a dominant american
ideology via hollywood films hell to the
star spangled yeah
the idea of a national cinema continues
to be explored deeply in film studies
and kind of uses the same basis as
auteur theory by looking at blockbuster
movies for common themes sentiments
tropes and archetypes we can gain an
idea of a broader american ideology that
means the values that are deemed
positive or negative and the aspirations
encouraged by the culture at large and
bay's work is arguably a pure uncensored
example of american national cinema his
movies do present an ideology but one
that bay doesn't necessarily own in
making movies that appeal to the largest
possible audience and disavowing meaning
in the process bay leaves the door wide
open for the dominant american ideology
to waltz in take his shoes off pop open
a can of budweiser and make itself right
at home this goes a long way in
explaining bay's work namely his films
are reflections of the most desirable
aspects within american culture and the
commodified state of them fittingly
bay's style was developed in advertising
leading to a lingering habit of
objectification plenty of directors get
critiqued for objectifying women but bay
doesn't stop there he objectifies
everything if an expensive supercar is
in the scene his camera will glide along
its angles highlighting its form and
presence same with military hardware
like fighter jets and state-of-the-art
guns base camera will focus on them
purely as objects rather than the things
they represent and speaking of shiny
objects the bay's camera often focuses
on various parts of conventionally
attractive women's bodies before
glancing to see if there's any hint of
emotion on their faces by way of box
office driven pragmatism bay's work is
filled with symbols of the american
ideal presented as unironically
desirable of course it's possible to
reflect the ideals of american culture
without straight up endorsing them and
plenty of directors are making that
commentary arguably minus the straight
up objectification the key is the
relevance of the imagery or sound to the
narrative being told critic kristen
thompson explored this through the idea
of cinematic excess here excess means
any stylistic elements that are included
in a movie seemingly for their own sake
rather than to contribute to the movie's
overarching message these elements don't
deepen the narrative but their presence
necessarily affects narrative meaning
simply by way of being there so when bae
includes say a scene where some rando 1
percenter shows off his car collection
and leeches on a woman look at the
curves elegant isn't it
beautiful
sensual
built to evoke the body of the ideal
woman or when the camera blatantly
lingers a little too long on a corporate
logo or when a big robot takes a fat
piss on john turturro you get classic
examples of cinematic excess
[Applause]
thompson thought that this kind of
excess comes from a director's personal
taste or preoccupations like jj abrams
with lens flare or tarantino with uh
with feet but interestingly most of the
excess and bay's work comes from the
capitalist pragmatism that defines his
approach to filmmaking because again bay
seems driven by the box office more than
anything else bay's cinematic excess
does clash with the apparent narrative
ambition of a storytelling like when he
shows american gis whooping and
hollering at their kills during the
attack on pearl harbor
when he makes sure we see the and we're
quoting here enemy scrotum of a
decepticon i am directly below
these classic bay moments of excess are
rooted in how the american ideal expects
people to behave all of bay's leading
men are templates for the ideals that
american culture broadly tells men they
need to aspire to and all of bay's
leading women are nope wait that's right
there aren't any with the rare exception
of ambulance where isa gonzalez actually
gets to do some stuff actresses in bay
films are pretty much just treated as
eye candy reinforcing american feminine
ideals of um
banging bods and silky hair other themes
include distrust of government
lionization of military force indulgent
product placement and gun fetishism all
of these textual hallmarks are direct
mirrors of the dominant american
ideology they're present in a bay movie
regardless of their objective relevance
to the narrative of the individual films
and bay's narratives will invariably at
some point or another halt to highlight
them in this way and through the lens of
thompson bay's movies are defined by a
kind of compromised cinematic excess
that is unmistakably american notably
this standard fair american xs is what
we reckon precludes bay from being
considered an auteur while he obviously
has a signature style and aesthetic
preoccupations any messaging in his work
lacks a sense of conviction so base
films are ideologically and
stylistically compromised surely that
gives us a definitive answer well not
quite because there's still the issue of
bay's undeniable skill as a director
even roger ebert after mentioned bay
critic recognized to the director's
technical chops and proficiency with
special effects this more than anything
else is arguably what draws people to
base films his visceral kinetic style of
action sucks us in through rapid-fire
cutting displacing us in time and space
in a way that prioritizes how the scene
makes us feel rather than our
comprehensive understanding of the exact
events unfolding a scholar stephen
shaviro explains
this makes bae a prime example of
post-continuity cinema which takes
inspiration from other art forms like
video games it basically abandons
classic editing conventions that
typically help the audience understand
the spatial temporality of the actions
on screen as shaviro puts it bae is the
new dw griffin or the anti-griffith as
he mixes and matches shots with no
concern for traditional articulations of
spatial and temporal continuity base
camera never stops whirling around the
carnage in ways that flout standard
filmmaking conventions and the elements
within the frame are a flurry of
movement too the end result
bayhem is chaotic impressionistic action
that defies comprehension in fact this
echoes the main issue people have with
bayhem that it's just overwhelming
cinematic noise but opposed to the
unconsidered ideology present in bay's
work his action sequences are a genuine
directorial expression used to convey
the reflexive adrenaline clouded state
that true danger puts us in as human
beings couple this with the bombastic
visuals that comprise base action
sequences and you get not only some of
the most striking spectacles in all of
blockbuster them but also something that
hits on deeper philosophical questions
of the things that captivate us visually
we can understand this with the help of
emmanuel kant who thought there are two
main types of things that give us visual
pleasure
beauty and the sublime khan saw beauty
as dealing with the contemplation of
order and harmony appreciated for its
own sake rather than for its utility or
value like a string of symmetrical
pearls the gentle swirls of a cockshell
or fresh basket of tater tots beautiful
things make us feel take the delicate
textures and lighten sofia coppola's the
virgin suicides or the set design of
grand budapest hotel these are beautiful
and their beauty can be comprehended the
sublime on the other hand deals with the
awe inspiring and the dangerous viewed
from a place of safety it's the things
that we can't comprehend because our
brains are just too damn limited or in
other words sublimity means the absence
of order or comprehension sublime fine
art a favorite of the romantic era might
depict an epic military battle or a ship
fighting its way through the angry sea
through kant's aesthetic lens bayhem is
a prime example of the sublime from
giant explosions to highway spanning car
wrecks to new york city being decimated
by meteors the situations that bay
depicts in his action scenes represent
levels of destruction that if faced in
real life would be so extensive in their
impact that we couldn't possibly reckon
with it and crucially the way in which
bay presents these situations is geared
towards non-comprehension potentially
leaving us with a gut feeling of
excitement or dread that has no
discernible point of origin within the
film it is as we think the kids would
say though we could be wrong a whole ass
vibe and we aren't alone in thinking so
new york times critic ao scott had this
to say about bay's latest film ambulance
bay's virtuosic flouting of the laws of
physics probability and narrative
coherence is meant to catapult you into
a zone of sublimity where melodramatic
emotion and adrenalized excitement fuse
into a whole new kind of sensation big
operatic feelings are both heightened
and lightened by propulsive speed and
overscaled action political theorist
william e connolly explores the wider
overall link between the sublime tinge
style of filmmaking and the ever
increasing speed of capitalism and
consumerism in our modern lives film to
connolly is a useful tool for us to
examine human methods of perception and
conception i.e how we view and think
about stuff that we see in this the
techniques used by directors to evoke
emotion generate engagement and affect
the way we think of the narrative are
analogous to the techniques of systems
like capitalism and consumerism conley
states that increasingly contemporary
film is geared more towards what he
calls the infra-conscious this is the
realm of reflex and impression that base
filmmaking does so well and there's
nothing inherently sinister about a
sublime action film but there is an
issue here namely that bay's american
excess and his sublime mayhem aren't
mutually exclusive his movies don't stop
evoking the american ideal just because
there's a chaotic action sequence both
are intertwined and bae seems to sense
this intuitively his action scenes often
take little micro breaks to let the
audience breathe probably in attempts to
alleviate tension or provide relief yet
this is where the american xs reliably
creeps back in we still get sexy shots
of supercars pulled right out of
commercials or weird cringy jokes i
stopped covering you it means i'm dead
but that ain't gonna happen or macho men
being almost comically dudely often all
at once and for connolly this connection
might be exactly in tune with what he's
diagnosed about the overall direction of
filmmaking he argues that the hyper
speed of modern film is a direct
reflection of the ever-growing waves in
which capitalism and consumerism seek to
overwhelm us as human beings if you've
ever been to times square you'd probably
catch our drift the goal of a flashing
neon sign or a billboard the size of a
building is like a michael bay film to
completely inundate our senses but of
course not quite so much that we get too
overwhelmed to run into the m m store
and buy a lifetime supply of blue
chocolates now we're not saying that
there's some conspiracy theory
subliminal messaging going on here or
that michael bay is a deep state agent
brainwashing us into supporting america
it's more of an unintended effect of his
visual aesthetic by splicing in these
moments that positively reflect american
excess as he learned to do in
advertising right into sequences that
favor gut reactions over heady
contemplation we're primed to view both
in the same way when our senses are
overwhelmed we stop trying to follow the
action and instead rely on the content's
impressionistic qualities using
thompson's thesis you could persuasively
argue that the chaos of bayhem primes us
to ingest the dominant ideology of
american capitalism at hand without the
benefit of critical distance so with
everything we've explored about bay's
work from the pragmatic box office
driven ideology to the very american
form of cinematic excess to the
purposively incomprehensible editing
style what are we left with well we
think there's a way to recognize all of
this and still enjoy bay's films what if
we view bay's work as a way for us to
engage with the realities of how the
systems we live within constantly prime
us to stick to the status quo or how
ideologies are malleable things that
will seep into any gaps they can in
forming our values and biases in not
resembling real life in any way shape or
form might the films of michael bay be
able to teach us how to live a little
more thoughtfully in our late late
capitalist hellscape and in that way
michael bay might just qualify as
unintentionally deep or as it's
officially known oopsy daisy smart but
what do you guys think is analyzing
bay's films even worth it should we
listen to the man himself and just
accept them as innocent mindless
entertainment sound off in the comments
hit subscribe like it's a big red
demolition button and don't forget to
ring that bell as always a big thanks to
our patrons for all your support and be
sure to check out the new features
available on our patreon page as always
thanks for watching
later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you